A há mình chỉ nên chính, tổng thống Mỹ đơn đơn trang bàn thành sắp lệng át thuy cào, đối với gỗ và đủ gỗ nhập khẩu.
Thều đó, gỗ trang với gỗ sẻ chỉ muốn thủy mười phần chăm, cho khi tự bết, tụi là phà bố và đủ nội thất bọng nề,
phải chự thuy thủy hâm lắm phần chăm.
Các mức thời có hiệu lực từ ngày 1 tháng 1 và dựa kiến tất cả mạnh và đồng năm hàng in thương trang mi sấu,
với mức tối ra tới 5 phần chăm cho một số mắt hàng, nếu không đặt đủ thỏe thuận thương mại với Washington.
Chuyên Mỹ, viện giãn điều 2-2 của đạo lột thông mại nằm mình chính trang bệm mít hơn,
cho rằng nhập khẩu gỗ đe số ăn ninh cú gia và làm suy yếu ngành gỗ trông lực.
Đồng thấy này, cái em hình chực kết tự cân tất cả đa, mồn cung gỗ lực nhất của Mỹ,
bồn nơi trường nhiều loại thui khăn nhau, nực lại, tất đủ tắc có hiệp định thương mại với Mỹ, như ăn ổ vình dịch bàm,
sẽ được hưởng mức thuy thấp hơn, sẽ đọng tự bười để mấy lắm phần chăm.
Puy định này dự bà, sẽ thật động xong giọc lìm trộc uống và cánh tình đu vại chim tòn câu.